hey this is presh talwalkar
can you make the number 24 from the
numbers 3 3 8 and 8.
you can only use the operations of
addition subtraction multiplication
division and grouping terms by
parentheses and you have to use all four
numbers
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the rest of the
video i'm going to present a hint before
i show the answer but then i will show
the solution in the remaining part of
the video
so give it a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video
so here's the hint
you might start out by thinking 8 times
3 is equal to 24
and you've reached 24 but you then
realize we need to use all four numbers
so one way to solve this problem is by
modifying this result
imagine that you could take
three numbers
three eight and eight to make eight
if you could do that
you would be done
the reason is that if you could get
three eight and eight to combine to be
eight
you would then have three numbers that
combine to be eight
multiplied by the remaining 3 to get 24.
now similarly if you could take 3 8 and
8 and combine them to make 1 8
you would also be done
this is because we could then do 3
divided by 1 8 and that would also equal
24.
now by the same logic if we can make 3
or 1 3 from the numbers 3 3 and 8 we
would also be done
because we would then do 8 multiplied
these 3 numbers to combine to be 3 and
that would be 24 or we could take 8
divided by 1 3 and that would also be
24.
so if you haven't figured it out this is
a huge hint
so see if you can use this to get to the
answer
once you're ready keep watching the
video i'm going to present the answer
so the trick is in this very last line
we are looking for three numbers 3 3 and
8 to combine to be one third
and the way we do that
is we do
three
minus eight thirds
this equals one third
we could then take eight divided by that
to get to 24.
and that's the answer
so there are many reasons this is a
difficult problem
it's hard to solve because first this is
the only solution out of all possible
combinations of the numbers
second the solution involves fractions
and two divisions
and finally the solution poses a
challenge for computers because
fractions like 1 3 can lead to rounding
and floating point errors so some
computer solvers will actually not find
the solution because they'll have
rounding and floating point errors
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at preshtalwalkar